bonsoir bienvenue à tous dans ce nouveau
7,8 le débat le décret est enfin paru au
journal officiel les écoles ont la
possibilité si elle le souhaite de
revenir à la semaine de quatre jours et
ce dès la rentrée prochaine
les communes qui souhaiterait franchir
le pas n'ont donc que deux mois pour se
réorganiser avec un délai si court la
majorité d'entre elles devraient choisir
de conserver la semaine de quatre jours
et demi celle ci avait été mise en place
rappelez vous en 2013 par le ministre de
l'époque vincent peillon mais cette
flexibilité offerte aux communes génère
beaucoup de mécontentement aussi bien du
côté des parents d'élèves que des
enseignants at on fait le bilan de la
semaine de quatre jours et demi
l'actuel ministre de l'éducation
souhaite t il revenir sur la réforme ou
parce qu'on les financements enfin que
dire du bien être de l'enfant dans tout
ça avec nous pour en débattre jean
michel fourgous vous êtes maire
d'elancourt jean-yves blé vous êtes
premier adjoint en charge de l'éducation
de la verrière et françois andré vous
êtes président de la fcpe des yvelines
bonsoir messieurs jean michel fourgous
quel est le choix de la ville
d'elancourt pour la rentrée 2010 est
quatre jours ou quatre jours et demi
égouttez le choix nous c'est l'enfant
l'enfant locaux est un laboratoire
il ya deux décès
et de la pédagogie en france par
l'éducation nationale
donc on a fait évoluer la pédagogie donc
on suit beaucoup sur le secteur primaire
le secteur primaire c'est le secteur où
il ya presque 40 % de jeunes qui
décrochent d'enfants qui décrochent
avant d'entrer en 6e donc l'effort doit
être fait sur le primaire entendait
pierre veut cela particulièrement et on
a été très vite les premiers en plus moi
je vais les caisses nationales jeu ça
chercheurs d'une crise nationale j'ai je
docteur en psychologie j'ai écrit
plusieurs bouquins sur l'éducation et
j'ai eu une mission parlementaire sur
sur sur l'école est elle encore on teste
les nouveaux outils pour faire évoluer
cette pédagogie parce qu'aujourd'hui la
un enfant apprend autant en dehors de
l'école que dans l'école donc il faut il
faut aujourd'hui modifier le logiciel de
compréhension des résultats scolaires de
l'enfant
il faut d'abord lui donnez lui augmenter
le plaisir d'apprendre avant de lui
injecter du savoir et puis deux augmenté
également le plaisir d'enseigner des
profs c'est l'objectif de ce qu'on fait
et il encourt donc on a regardé cette
forme avec des traits particuliers
quand on a vu cette réforme
arrivé en disant c'est la réforme des
rythmes scolaires non déjà faut pas dire
autre chose que la vérité cette réforme
n'a jamais été une réforme des rythmes
scolaires bien vous le disiez très bien
tout à l'heure
il faut effectivement répartir
la scolarité les cours différemment par
exemple les coupures de six mois
quasiment effectivement c'est pas bon
alors mais on en parlera après nous
c'était toujours table vous ces quatre
jours très bien j'arrive l'est du côté
de la verrière pas de changement à la
rentrée
non non on a décidé de maintenir à
quatre jours et demi on pense d'ailleurs
que c'est
bonne solution en deux mots enfin parce
que les enfants s'y retrouve
les parents aussi j'ai entendu tout à
l'heure vous disiez le mécontentement
on n'a pas ce sentiment là les parents
sont contents apprécié les nappes
activités périscolaires ce qu'on y fait
à l'intérieur c'est aussi une manière
différente d'apprendre à une manière
différente pour les enfants
d'appréhender le monde 1 à travers un
certain nombre d'activités culturelles
artistiques sportives aussi bien sûr
donc non on a n'auraient pas l'occasion
de faire si donc ces activités
périscolaires n'avait pas été mise en
place par les communes
non je pense pas non en effet c'est
aussi une ouverture à un certain nombre
d'enfants qui n'ont pas accès à des
loisirs culturels type musical parce
qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens tout
simplement et la vie de pas offrir ce
type d'activité et donc amener l'enfant
à vers d'autres vers d'autres mondes
finalement françois andré de votre côté
qu'en pensent les parents d'élèves que
vous représentez alors lié à ce qu'en
pensent les parents d'élèves parce que
ils réfléchissent aussi en fonction de
leur organisation de temps familial donc
on peut dire que finalement on est
partagés essais j'ai vu aussi
au travers des déclarations des autres
fédérations au cdn que à la pp à l'énap
également les parents sont partagés donc
si on leur laisse la liberté de choisir
ils vont choisir instinctivement ce qui
arrange leur temps leur vie de famille
dion est alors qu'en fait il faut placer
le débat ailleurs donc ma fédération
souhaite pas forcément d'ailleurs cette
réforme là mais elle elle elle est
favorable à la semaine continue
d'apprentissage et des discontinuités
sans discontinuité dans l'école tous les
matins ou disons tous les jours avec des
temps en accord avec les rythmes
biologiques de l'enfant dans la journée
il a des pics d'attention dont il faut
profiter
alors évidemment c'est l'organisation de
toute une société qui est derrière il ya
ceux qui travaillent de l'école il ya
les maires qui sont en ligne
il ya des parents qui aussi avait un peu
pris l'habitude de donc pendant un court
laps de temps parce que le retour à 4
jours ce n'est pas tout à fait vrai la
réforme de 2008 n'était pas vraiment une
réforme xavier darcos avait proposé
qu'on passe l'école de 26 à 24 heures ça
c'est un point très important et plus
deux heures de soutien pour les élèves
qui en ont besoin
et ensuite il et puis ensuite le
président de la république à l'époque
avait dit on doit rendre le samedi matin
aux familles donc xavier darcos s'est
retrouvé face à une équation un peu
différente dit on doit supprimer le
samedi matin
et puis il ya des élèves pour qu'ils y
aura quand même 26 heures par comment on
répartit ça dans la semaine et les
conseils d'école de france devait
décider de l'organisation de ce temps et
ils ont basculé naturellement vers le 4
jours mais ce n'était pas dans la loi
c'était pas la semaine de quatre jours
et au passage et je le dis à tous les
maires qui demandent le retour à quatre
jours nous avons perdu deux heures
d'école pour un certain nombre d'enfants
donc qu'il a il ya un problème de fond
c'est à dire qu'il n'y a pas de projet
quand on dit on veut revenir aux quatre
jours en fait on instaure une nouvelle
semaine de 24 heures et donc il ya des
enfants qui ont perdu delà des heures de
classe dans cette affaire jean michel
fourgous quand vous entendez
effectivement qu'il faut concentrer les
cours fondamentaux le matin parce que
niveau de concentration des élèves est
plus important vous l'entendez ça alors
voilà le niveau de concentration
c'est ça qui nous intéresse c'est
l'enfant au delà du coût que je rappelle
que c'est en pratique est après des
financements aura coûté mon avis entre 6
et 10 milliards sur quatre ans si
l'histoire
mais je connais bien le dos il a donc
voilà alors la concentration c'est clair
c'est que si vous augmentez la fatigue
des enfants que vous le constatez par
vous-même parents ou bien par les profs
ou par d'autres animateurs bon il est
clair que vous touchez donc à la
concentration et donc vous toucher aux
résultats scolaires
ce qui hélas le grand tabou et il est
quand même surprenant qu'une telle
réforme qui a bousculé déstabiliser les
équipes pédagogiques de toute la france
il n'y ait jamais eu d'étude d'impact
sincère sincère j'ai bien et aurait
jailli jeu seul le seul qui a annoncé
une étude scientifique c'est monsieur
hamon et il avait dit que c'était de
montrer que les bénéfices pour l'enfant
était immense et on lui a demandé les
détails de cette étude est visible à du
est classé secret défense puisque
personne n'a jamais vu cette étude met
donc c'est le seul qui avait dit qu'il y
avait une étude
donc aujourd'hui c'est suffisamment
grave là c'est le premier budget d'une
commune c'est la preuve premier objectif
d'une dune d'une ville c'est ce travail
en primaire donc à l'école
et là je veux dire content je dois dire
que ces liens efficaces
ce serait inefficace elle se révèle bien
sûr infinançable en plus c'est pas rien
quand vous retrouve baisse vos moyens de
20% petit je vous rappelle que dans les
cinq gares de lyon nous abaisser nos
moyens dans les communes de 20% c'est
énorme
vous m'auriez dit c'est un jour
et qu on vous rajoute cette réforme qui
qui vous fait qui touche aux résultats
scolaires des enfants c'est ça qui est
grave c'est sacré j'avais donc on est
déjà je sais pas quoi 24e et 25e à
blizzard il est inadmissible qu'on ait
pu engager une telle étude
sans mesure et on nous disait que ça
coûterait rien je me souvient vincent
peillon disais ça coûtera 0 je lui ai
dit mais vous rigolez ça coûtera 300 400
euros en fait ça coûte je crois à 231
euros d'après la mfr de france est en
gros dans certaines communes chez moi ça
coûte 400 robes au ghana par enfin par
donc et par an donc faut bien vous
rendre compte que c'est pas normal qu'on
lance un truc pareil
kiki et inefficace on n'a pas mesuré
ensuite qu'on n'a même pas mesurer le
coût réel de cette réforme
et puis aucune concertation ça a été une
mesure imposée sans concertation on voit
bien que les sondages montraient déjà
que les parents étaient contre aux deux
tiers si c'était pas les trois quarts
idem les profs et idem les équipes
municipales on a imposé
comment at on pu imposer un truc pareil
où les deux tiers des français qu'on
soit profs parents ou ville était contre
ils avaient raison d'être contre c'était
pas par rapport j'entends le message de
notre ami qui dit il faut pas écouter
les parents ou les profs parce que il
juste par rapport à l'intérêt non je
crois qu'aujourd'hui même les élèves
d'ailleurs rien et même un garçon qui
m'a dit un jour mais demandé aux élèves
mais c'était pas prévu mais on l'a
demandé aux élèves lisez-vous s'esquive
répondu mercredi parce que il faut des
coupures
il faut gagner allez-y donc chez vous
chez vous ça marche
laperrière et ça fonctionne cette façon
parce que je pense parce qu'on a bien
préparé en fait cette réforme et on a
tablé sur la concertation s'est appuyé
avec la ligue de l'enseignement d'abord
pour permettre d'objectiver le débat au
sein de la communauté éducative parents
enseignants animateurs à genre les
services municipaux les élus bien
évidemment on s'est entouré aussi
enfin on a eu l'appui et l'intervention
du professeur hubert montagner sur cette
question là une matinée un qui a qui est
intervenu auprès de la communauté
éducative là encore pour a expliqué
les raisons de cette réforme et le
bien-fondé finalement et concrètement
vos enfants bénéficient de quel genre
d'activités périscolaires pour qu'on
comprenne lors des activités artistiques
musicales avec la même des la musique la
maison de la musique et de la danse des
professeurs donc ils se déplacent et qui
viennent sur les temps
[Musique]
d'horribles tambours comment accès à la
rippe des de la danse bien sûr aussi
des activités civiques un des activités
sur la question environnementale avec
une association qui se déplace aussi là
également qui est ville verte avec
de l'expression corporelle de déclic
théâtre pour l'épanouissement et est là
comment la promotion et la maîtrise de
son corps et de sa gestuelle et sa
parole voilà ses skis et vous arrivez à
financer tout ça et on arrive à financer
tout ça bien sûr et on arrive à le
financer parce qu'on a les aides pour
choix être là ou à raison il faut être
clair là-dessus on sent des banques
l'état avait prévu un affront non enfin
moi j'ai toujours dit et je pense que
c'était très fort c'est 50 euros par
élève et c'est une réforme qui a calqué
du sens et qu'il faut faire il fallait
faire je pense qu'elle aurait dû être
porté par l'état
simplement pour le un point de vue
d'équité sur le territoire d'égalité
traire prise en charge financièrement
total l'état et géré mais peut-être même
par l'éducation nationale pour ce qui
concerne toutes les activités
périscolaires à les nouvelles activités
périscolaires je pense que ça aurait dû
être gérée par l'état oui parce que on
voit bien que en fonction des
territoires en fonction des moyens des
communes
les activités qui sont proposées sont
pas forcément les mêmes quoi et donc là
il ya quand même à une égalité de
traitement ça on peut pas c'est
malheureux mais c'est comme ça justement
françois andré inégalité de traitement
est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est un
débat communes riches contre communes
pauvres est ce qu on entend un passé
critique la cua si vous dites que versa
enfin qu'est ce que vous voulez dire
communes riches et communes pauvres
c'est qu'il ya des combines qui ont été
un jour de sortir c'est pas une question
de communes riches et communes pauvres
il ya des communes pauvres qui reste au
rythme
il ya aussi en milieu rural et semi
rural d'autres expériences qui ont été
menées avec des seniors et retraités etc
qui sont bénévoles
donc il ya eu un enrichissement de ses
lacs des acteurs différents on parlait
localement pour essayer de 2 autour de
l'enfant et la prend des apprentissages
d'avoir un projet commun localement
donc il ya eu des expériences qu'ont
marché en france et ce que dit le
sénateur carle qui on aurait pu
s'inspirer qu'on aurait pu s'inspirer de
ce qui a bien marché et faire évoluer la
réforme je crois que c'était ça la clé
et j'aime beaucoup encore une fois ce
qu'on l'a dit avant donc ce rapport des
sénateurs qui étaient donc là
être surtout parvenir aux quatre jours
qui dit clairement que c'est que c'est
une erreur et que c'est probablement
dommageable mais que bien sûr et là je
la critique est tout à fait valable
la réforme portait en germe son échec en
en n'étant pas capable de s'évaluer en
n'ayant pas prévu les jalons de
dévaluation donc actuellement je vois
pas comment on peut évaluer une réforme
qui n'est appliquée que depuis trois ans
à une réforme aussi fondamentale
appliquée que depuis trois ans et il
aurait fallu attendre la sortie d'une
cohorte complète de cinq ans de cp à cm2
pour savoir un peu comment que comment
se passaient les évaluations de cm2 par
exemple par rapport à l'accord précédent
c'est ça qu'il faut faire quand on est
un peu expert en se dit faut d'abord des
bilans faut d'abord évaluer et donc il y
avait des marges de progression c'est ce
que dit le sénateur carle mais il faut
pas en faire qu'une question d'argent je
trouve que c'est grave d'en faire une
question d'argent
parce que l'éducation devrait partir
pour les municipalités
c'est acquis mais s'occuper des écoles
aussi c'est un coût pour les
municipalités le globalement toute
l'éducation en france un coup pour
toutes les collectivités territoriales
des raisons c'est pas la question c'est
pas c'est pas l'argent c'est qu'est ce
qu'on veut pour nos enfants dans ce pays
c'est ça qui est en jeu quand même deux
rapports médicaux importants celui d'une
cellule de crise et celui de l'académie
nationale de médecine en 2010 ce qui a
vraiment tiré la sonnette d'alarmé
et c'est à partir de ce travail des
experts de l'académie nationale de
médecine que les gens se sont mis en
route pour essayer de réformer le
système scolaire français qui est à part
dans toute l'europe
peut-être dans le monde d'ailleurs en
nombre de jours d'école par an jean
michel flos là dessus et sur les
différents tracés rapport qui existe des
rapports médicaux et qui préconise
effectivement un étalement des
enseignements with you le musée nature
car les beaucoup plus prudent que cela
en fait il dit aussi qu'il n'ya pas
d'étude sérieuse scientifiques ont été
faites bon et c'est tout le problème
c'est que c'est séquence où il n'y a pas
d'évaluation d'impact de cette mesure
qui était fait bon comme ça fait trois
ans qu'on s'est quand même ses 15 ans
c'est court ça concerne nos enfants oui
mais vu le coup vu que ça met en cause
comme une tasse colère oui
non je vous rappelle que des réponses
claires ces trois choses 1 s'est étalé
sur toute l'année c'est pas possible
les militaires dans la cause des
fédérations de tourisme bien sûr ça
bessèges chamboule tout c'est les
vacances et pourrait donc c'est pas
possible que ce soit la gauche à droite
ils ont tous échoué deux suivants es20
bon deuxième deuxième chose c'est qu'il
faut qu'il y ait moins d'heures de cours
par jour
c'est pas le cas de cette réforme ce qui
est plus d'heures de travail
ils sont ils sont plus fatigués et ce
que dit les chronobiologistes donc parce
que là ils vous disent il faut deux
coupures dans la semaine il faut une
coupure le mercredi et une coupure le
dimanche parce qu'en fait il faut pas
que la désynchronisation du cerveau de
l'enfant soit comme ça soit trop il ait
trop d'écart bon c'est ça la grande
terre or cette réforme ne répond
absolument
ce jour résolu
avec le samedi matin finalement oui mais
c'est pas le samedi matin qui était
choisissez une batterie nimh est bon
donc l'âge donc je trouve quand même que
on a on n'a pas dit les choses aux gens
et il faut on peut on peut tester des
choses mais il s'agit des enfants
je trouve et en plus à désorganiser les
équipes pédagogiques j'ai jamais vu un
tel cirque soudan des équipes
pédagogiques
on mélange est déjà affaibli ferrasse
qu'elle organise écoutez le résultat au
bout de trois ans je vous dire c'est pas
satisfaisant quand vous quand vous
prenez des animateurs 45 minutes pour
une journée voulait faire venir chez
vous pour 45 minutes ils ont trente
minutes ou trois quarts d'heure de
trajet il n'a pas pu finaliser ce métier
on l'a vu en plus on mélangeait des gens
qui avaient des formations pour les
grands différente on en arrivait mais à
voir que le prof été remis en cause dans
la pédagogie par un animateur
il faut bien voir c'est très compliqué
eu des problèmes de locaux il ya eu des
problèmes j'irai de management il ya eu
des profs donc donc de la
désorganisation et aujourd'hui en plus
elles ne fonctionnent pas parce que
beaucoup de villes vous ne le dit pas
mais on abandonner purement et
simplement la qualité de ce été happé au
départ qui était qui était avec des
théâtres en a créé les animateurs ne
revenez pas est en fait qu est ce qui se
passait ou ça devenait de la balle au
prisonnier
et puis d'inégalités comme blog vous
invite à voir mais c'est vrai qu'on n'a
jamais vu une mesure aussi inégalitaire
vous avez des villes où vous avez des
cours de piano de violon et d'équitation
et d'autres vous avez la balle au
prisonnier
le fait qu'une réforme de l'éducation
nationale jules ferry de se retourner
dans sa tombe
au niveau de l'égalité gerland c'est
franchement une réforme qui est
inégalitaire gravement inégalitaire qui
est inefficace et ça c'est grave et
quitte infinançable est clair c'est
incompréhensible d'avoir lancé cela sans
et d'un pack sans concertation en la
reja les acteurs jungle est profondément
les gaines et inégalitaire c'est pas
tout à fait faux au moins dans les
propositions d'activités sur l'ensemble
du territoire français s'est passé pour
c'est pas faux ça
injuste non puisque lll et elle
fonctionne quand même s'est mis en place
ça a pris du temps mais c'est en place
d'une risque ce qui est ce qui est
dommageable c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
recul il n'y a pas de recul on prend pas
le temps de regarder ce qui s'est passé
ce qui a marché ce qui n'a pas marché et
se dire comment on fait pour avancer
mieux mais dans l'idée des 4
jours et demi des cinq matinées sait et
c'est quand même ça c'est fonder le
problème des animateurs effectivement on
a dit il ya des premiers un problème de
recrutement finalement pas assez de bafa
et c'est un problème que vous avez
rencontrés à la verrière oui bien sûr
comme toutes les collectivités on a
rencontré ce problème
on a affaire à des jeunes gens qui
démarre souvent dans la vie
professionnelle
il y a des codes à prendre il ya des
postures à avoir donc tout ça ça se
travaille ça et ça prend du temps et
donc là de ce point de vue là c'est vrai
que en amont ça n'a pas été assez
travaillé il a fallu former dans
l'urgence des milliers d'animateurs 1
qui se sont retrouvés ensuite sur
terrain à organiser des activités pour
lesquelles il n'avait pas assez
d'expérience pour que ça tourne
correctement mais maintenant au fil de
l'eau et du temps qui passe et des
encadrants qui s'en occupe on voit bien
que l'aller ils ont gagné en compétences
qu'ils ont gagné en assurance et ce
qu'il propose c'est de mieux en mieux 1
c'est de mieux en mieux structurée dans
ce but là c'est plutôt intéressant
le probable le problème c'est si on
arrête qu'est ce qu'on fait de tous ces
gens qu'on a formé tant des animateurs
il ya un travail un travail donc là
c'est aussi une question qu'il faut
aussi se poser transcenderait sur ce
point là sur l'enfant en particulier
comment est-ce qu'on peut expliquer
qu'on apprend mieux la même somme
finalement de choses en huit de mes
journées au lieu de neuf sages conseils
faut qu'on m'explique pourquoi c'est
mieux en huit de mes journées et surtout
je le comprends pas qu'on puisse pas
réalisée que dans des évidemment des
familles c'est pour ça que les parents
représentant les parents représentants
représente aussi une certaine classe
sociale dans les conseils d'école et
c'est bien sûr que eux se disent tout à
fait capable de gérer leurs enfants le
mercredi et est d'organiser des
activités et de les inscrire et c'est
donc il mais pour toutes les autres
familles que faisaient les enfants le
mercredi
il faisait rien donc c'est une journée
perdue en fait dans d apprentissage
donc quand on quand on peut s'occuper de
son enfant le soutenir
le soutenir aux devoirs le soir en
rentrant bien sûr tout va bien bien sûr
il ya une catégorie d'enfants qui est
capable de supporter la pression
scolaire et 6 heures de travail par jour
mais il y en a beaucoup d'autres qui ne
sont pas qu'ils ne peuvent pas et qui
n'ont pas de soutien chez eux
et bien ce que de l'école doit apporter
c'est précisément ce soutien et je pense
que dans l'étalement des apprentissages
dans la semaine il vaut mieux que les
enfants et l'école tous les jours parce
que c'est c'est mieux que de ne rien
faire pour les familles qui n'ont pas
des moyens financiers ou qui ne peuvent
pas les soutenir scolairement chez eux
jean michel fourgous à elancourt vous
avez sûrement des familles qui sont dans
ce cas là et qui ont apprécié qu'ils
apprécient voilà d'avoir l'école qui
prend en charge leur emploi mercredi
mais de toute façon dans les 15 jours
vous vous ouvrez vous centre de loisirs
donc pour les gens qui vous qui voulez
vous confient leurs enfants et on est
des ateliers nous sommes des ateliers
avec des rambos on a une centaine de
robots quand même en cours et on l'a ils
ont tous des tablettes regrets mercredi
lors de sa conférence il évasion il en
alla alors là moi c'est pas par rapport
au t1 p mais demain avec la nouvelle
organisation
vous vous retrouvez comme avant les
centres de loisirs et de toutes les
communes de france sont payants et des
prix différents voilà mes mais au moins
au moins ces professionnels on ya des
êtres des animateurs là dessus qu'ils
sont formés voilà c'est pas de
l'improvisation comme on a vu avec une
instabilité parce qu'il faut quand même
le dire
l'instabilité le turnover qu'on a vu
puisque on se bat et même quelquefois
pour recruter les toutes les communes
chercher des animateurs bien biens
professionnels et on ne trouvait plus
confirmé que c'était
c'était même de la surenchère qui va
entraîner comme si ces surenchères mais
il y avait c'est vrai une difficulté au
quotidien oui parce que en fonction des
communes en fonction des salaires
proposés bain en effet
généreux ça pouvait générer de la
concurrence bien évidemment donc là donc
non mais on a essayé ce qu'on nous dise
pas devant nous imposer je vous rappelle
quelqu'un une libre gestion des pas
marqué mais on a essayé ça ne marche pas
donc l'intérêt de l'élève sait qu'on
arrête le plus vite possible parce
qu'appartenant cette touche à la
concentration était là il faut arrêter
immédiatement un mot de conclusion
chacun on arrive à la fin de cette
émission françois andré alors on va
réinstaurer ou plutôt instaurer un
nouveau un nouveau rythme où il y aura
24 heures pour tous donc là j'insiste
sur le fait qu'il ya des enfants qui ont
perdu au passage
donc je voudrais bien savoir quel est le
projet du ministre parce que je pense
qu'il ya autre chose derrière
il doit y avoir des contreparties soyons
il a dit qu'il souhaitait pas revenir
sur le dossier s'est pas compris ça
c'est pas compris ça je pense qu'il
enregistra question de l'étalement des
vacances
je pense qu'il y aura la question de
devoir faire rentrer à la maison donc
savoir qui comment ça va être organisé
donc je pense qu'il ya d'autres choses
derrière donc là j'attends la suite mais
en tout cas on va être dans la
particularité européenne ne sera le seul
pays d'europe à quatre jours par semaine
26 à la semaine continue de 5 jours 1 la
belgique à quatre jours et demi donc
nous on va être encore le les derniers
du peloton à 144 jours d'école seulement
par an contre une moyenne de 190 dans
toute l'europe
je ne vois pas comment on va remonter le
niveau est remonté nos classements
internationaux
bizarre donc expliquer moi il va falloir
qu'on m'explique vraiment comment 144
jours ont fait le travail
j'arrive les entreprises de votre côté
la réforme là le dit elle s'arrête mais
en même temps
on a encore un an 1 faut-il espérer que
dans cette année qui va s'écouler on
puisse relancer le débat
avoir une discussion et essayer de
construire quelque chose d'un peu plus
solide parce que sinon en effet je pense
que vous avez raison on va dans le mur
voilà et c'est quand même de vrais avec
le ministre viennent vers vous et oui je
pense oui qu'ils auraient tout intérêt à
la question mais en tout cas vous restez
avec ses quatre à quatre jours et demi
maintenant si le ministre demain et nous
dit ceux qui sont passés à quelques
jours restent à quatre jours et ceux qui
veulent rester à quatre jours et demi en
gardant les avantages financiers nous
dit reste voilà aucun souci de ce point
de vue là mais je ne pense pas que ce
soit dans les labs as du ministre ce
genre de trucs vous avez peur de vous et
que les financements disparaissent à ces
défis nos sens des départs est ce
forcément il va falloir pour qu'on
regarde en toute logique du financement
libéré par les villes qui passa quatre
jours devrait vous reverser ces phases
finales
voilà indirectement jean michel fabre
notre occlusion oui non mais c'est pas
qu'il a peur des paires de seins porto
il a perdu les 50 euros peut-être que ça
n'est pas monsieur blé je vous dis ça ne
restera que pour certaines communes
donc voilà donc qui n'existe plus pour
2010 est simplement l'intérêt de
l'enfant doit dépasser la politique
cette réforme c'est l'intérêt politique
et de miner l'intérêt de l'enfant donc
aussi bien qu'on revienne et qu'on parle
entre spécialistes entre gens qui
expérimentent qui travaille vraiment sur
le secteur primaire et on me et qu'on se
concerte avec le modèle européen aussi
qu'on voit mais mais cet accord c'est
tout rires oui je pense que cet outil là
je vous dire va aider considérablement à
réconcilier les enfants qu'ils étaient
moins d'abord avec l'école avec le
plaisir d'apprendre c'est ça que l'on
vise mousser ses d'autres méthodes
pédagogiques mais rien n'est éloignée de
cette espèce de débat sur la news corp
qui est obsolète aujourd'hui avec
l'organisation la modernité qui existe
aujourd'hui
ce débat est obsolète donc passons aux
choses sérieuses à l'avenir à la
modernité
merci jean michel fourgous vous n'êtes
pas d'accord mais on va s'asseoir la
semaine continue merci on va s'arrêter
là merci à vous on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau débat
très bonne soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]